[Music]
death is the enemy
the first enemy and the last
[Music]
the enemy always leaves and we still
need to fight him
okay what he's got on
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from my Game of Thrones season 7
episode 6 breakdown video there is a lot
to discuss about this episode so let's
just get right into it the episode
begins beyond the wall with Jon Snow and
company on their mission to capture a
white that they need to take back down
south to King's Landing in hopes of
gaining the support from Cersei
Lannister after they show her that the
threat is real while they are travelling
in search of the dead
tormund Giantsbane says something very
interesting to Jon Snow torment asked
John about the Dragon Queen because he
wants to know what Jon thought of her
himself
Jon says that she will only help him if
he bends the knee and up until now Jon
has refused to bend the knee to Daenerys
Targaryen Jon knows that the northern
Lords would never stand beside him if he
bent the knee to a Targaryen Jon has
also had many influences in his life
during his short relationship with Mance
Rayder Jon grew to respect Mane's even
though he was looked at as the enemy Jon
admired what he was able to do and what
he was willing to sacrifice for his
people even though he thought it was a
terrible mistake
tormund tells John that he spent too
much time with the free folks so now he
doesn't want to bend the knee torment
also says that mance was a proud man who
never bent the knee but how many of his
people had to die because he refused you
could see that Jon acknowledged what
torment had said and I think he might
have even been surprised to hear someone
like torment say something like that Jon
knows he's going to run the risk of
losing his support from the northern
houses by bending the knee to Daenerys
Targaryen but I think he will do what is
needed in order to save as many people
as he can the other northern Lords have
not seen the things that Jon has seen
beyond the wall but if they have they
would bend the knee - and get all the
help that they can when the knight king
and his army gets out of the wall and
the dead are marching in everyone's
backyard they will realize their
differences will have to be put aside in
order to survive in once the northerners
see that Daenerys is also willing to
risk her own life and sacrifice her
dragons to save everyone else they will
grow to respect her - this episode also
had a ton of very obvious foreshadowing
in it I think it's safe to say that Jon
and Daenerys are probably going to end
up having a child together or I guess I
should say Daenerys will get pregnant by
Jon but I can't say whether or not the
we'll survive the pregnancy there was at
least three different references in this
episode alone about John having children
and Daenerys being able to have children
while they're hiking John pulls drawer
to the side and he offers to give
Longclaw back to Jorah since the sword
had been in his family for so long but
George does not accept his offer because
he said his father Lord Commander
Mormont gave it to John for a reason
Jorah tells John to keep the sword he
says it's going to serve you well in
your children after you and actually
like the way that they did this scene I
think it would be great if John did have
a child of his own even if he does die
it would be nice for him to have a piece
of him left behind to carry on his
legacy and carry his sword back in
Winterfell Arya confronts Sansa about
the letter she wrote to their brother
Robb Stark Arya is angry because Sanjay
asked Rob to come to King's Landing and
swear fealty to Joffrey but what's even
worse than that is Arya is angry because
she thinks their father was killed with
sons his help she says that sons have
betrayed their entire family while she
stayed with the Lannisters and there was
actually a few different things that I
thought about this first I just want to
say that I do appreciate Arya's passion
for wanting to protect her family but I
think she was out of line
Arya really has no idea Sansa was left
with little choice but to write Rob that
letter and sones it did try to help Ned
avoid his execution has Arya already
forgot that she actually served Tywin
Lannister while he planned the war
against Robb Stark and has Arya already
forgot that Jagan Agoura offered to kill
any three people of her choice but Arya
never had him kill Tywin Lannister who
went on to orchestrate the massacre at
the red wedding personally I'm not a big
songs of fan but I don't think she
deserved to be verbally attacked here by
Arya Arya also knows that Littlefinger
conspired what Tywin Lannister yet Arya
is letting him walk freely around
Winterfell without ever confronting him
I think Orion needs to realize that she
is being played by a little finger and
she's doing exactly what he wanted her
to do I don't blame her for feeling
protective over her family but she just
went about it the wrong way in the next
scene torment into hound provide us with
some comedy relief and I must say I had
been waiting a long time for torment and
the Hound to have some screen time
together I actually thought it was
pretty funny when torment stuck his
finger
out at the hound and he said he was
kissed by fire - I was just waiting for
the Hound to grab that finger and snap
it off you could also tell torment
hasn't been around any woman for a while
because he starts to tell the Hound
about his fantasies of having children
with bran that would one day grow up and
conquer the world can you imagine if
Corman and Breen did have a child
together their kid could probably grow
up and take down a dragon without using
any weapons I also really like the next
scene - with John and beric Dondarrion I
was actually talking a gray area one day
and we were discussing what we liked
about Game of Thrones so much and we
both came to the agreement that some of
the best scenes are when characters are
just travelling together and talking I
love big epic battles but I also love
when characters just talk about regular
things or even deeper things like what
is their purpose in life some of the
best dialogue comes from when characters
are travelling in this show berrak
starts talking to John about Ned Stark
and he tells him he doesn't look like
him so that must mean John looks like
his mother Liana it's not often that we
ever get to see Jon Snow happy or even
satisfied but for a very brief second
John comes to the realization about what
his purpose is and it's very subtle but
he almost cracks a smile when he
realizes it he won't find much joy while
he is here but what he can do is fight
for those who can't fight for themselves
he can be the shield that guards the
realms of men that's all he really needs
to understand back on Dragonstone
Daenerys continues to fall in love with
her nephew and karien confirms it there
was also a lot of foreshadowing in this
scene as well Daenerys talks about
meeting Cersei for the parler scene when
John gets back with the white Tyrion
says that they were going to show up
with two armies and three dragons but
unfortunately later in this episode one
of those dragons died so now they will
only be showing up with two dragons and
this may give Cersei even more
confidence that the dragons can be
killed it's very clear that Daenerys
isn't as unstoppable as she once seemed
the next discussion Tyrion and Daenerys
has has a few different layers of
foreshadowing in it
Daenerys wants to break the wheel and do
things differently than her ancestors
did before her especially her father the
Mad King and Tyrion asked her how she
plans on keeping the wheel broken after
she is dead what system can they put in
place to ensure this
cariann mentions that Daenerys can't
have any children and this makes the
second time in this episode they have
foreshadowed someone having a baby one
time with John in a second what Daenerys
so it's getting pretty obvious to me
that John and Daenerys will hook up and
she will get pregnant she should not be
able to have any children anymore
but I think the death of her dragon
Viserion will be a type of payment that
will allow her to get pregnant with an
actual child marry master once told
Daenerys that only death can pay for
life so I think vissarion's death will
allow Daenerys to get pregnant again but
possibly this time she can actually give
birth to the child I also got the vibe
that Daenerys might die after listening
to this discussion about naming a
successor
Daenerys didn't even want to speak about
it until she actually gets the crown but
I don't know if she's ever going to see
that day not only could I see her dying
in battle but I could also see her dying
during childbirth and once again death
would pay for life we saw her vision at
the house of the undying and she was
never actually able to touch the throne
personally I don't think she will
besides John Snow is the true heir after
all back up north beyond the wall John
and his companions run into a freakin
zombie polar bear with glowing blue eyes
and I thought this was a great team the
weapons the night King has in his army
are just getting crazier and crazier
first we saw him with three giants at
the beginning of this season now he has
a polar bear and he eventually gets a
dragon there are actually snow bears in
the books as well but it seems as if the
show is starting to bend the rules about
how whites and White Walkers can be
killed
they caught the polar bear on fire but
it didn't die just kept right on
fighting since the bear didn't die by
fire then that must mean it's a white
Walker bear but Jorah ran up and stabbed
it with the dragonglass dagger and the
bear died immediately but it didn't
shatter into pieces like the White
Walkers typically do which I thought was
strange I don't know if this polar bear
was supposed to be a white or a white
Walker bear whites usually die by fire
but now they die with dragonglass - for
some reason but unfortunately during all
of this Thorus of Muir was badly injured
the hound would have been dead if it
wasn't for thoris stepping in while the
Hound turned into reek when he saw the
fire The Hound seriously needs to snap
out of this at some point or he's going
to end up getting other people killed
back in Winterfell Littlefinger suggests
asana that brand should be put on
standby in case arya tries anything
slick Littlefinger's plan is working
perfectly right now he needs Arya out of
the way so he can have songs all to
himself to manipulate an influence
if Littlefinger can have sons all to
himself he can be back in position to
control everything you can tell a little
fingers plan was starting to rub off on
songs at two she was definitely
contemplating his suggestion arya needs
to speak up about Littlefinger
conspiring with Tywin or Brae needs to
look into the past and see the crimes
that Littlefinger has committed this
needs to be stopped at once or else one
of the stork sisters could end up dead
but they're going to wake up soon enough
in Arya will kill Littlefinger with his
own dagger the next scene had some
foreshadowing in it as well torment
spots a small group of whites walking
with one of the white walkers so they
plan to attack the small group and
capture one of those whites I have to be
honest with you though it almost felt as
if this was all a setup when brain sent
the Ravens up to spy on the army they
were all marching together towards
Eastwatch but now that Jon and them are
up there they just suddenly stumble on a
dozen of them wandering around it kind
of felt out of place I thought the
entire army should be marching together
still non-stop unless the night King had
all of this planned in order to get a
dragon to knock down the wall but that
wouldn't make much sense either because
that would mean the night King had no
other way of getting south unless he had
a dragon which would be stupid because
if Daenerys never took her dragons up
there then the night King could have
never made itself what also made it feel
like a setup was because the night king
and his White Walkers just settled their
horses as Jon Snow and company were
stuck in the middle of the lake the
night King brings the cold with him so
he could have frozen that Lake anytime
he wanted but he didn't he could have
thrown his ice spear at them too while
they were stuck they're just sitting
ducks but he never did that either
that's what makes me think he was
waiting for Daenerys to show up almost
like he knew she would come we know the
night King has some kind of greenseer
ability because he entered brains vision
and he physically touched brain two so
you might actually be able to see how
things are going to play out in the
future but I could be dead wrong about
this maybe it's just bad writing or a
way of adding drama to the scene but
anyway
he's John and his team ambushed the
whites and white Walker and what I loved
about this was how John snow went right
for the white Walker himself that
definitely took balls
but when John killed the white Walker
all of this skeleton white
simultaneously dropped to which means
whenever you kill the Creator their
creations die to this white Walker must
have raised these whites himself which
is very interesting because we haven't
been told this yet every white Walker
must be capable of raising the dead but
only the knight King can raise a large
group at once like he did at hardhome so
now it's very obvious how to defeat the
whole army if you kill the knight King
it will kill everything he created and
controls after they subdued the white
John sends Gendry back to east was so he
can get word to Daenerys that they're in
trouble and I'm not actually sure how
John knew ginjury was the fastest one
there I'm guessing just because he was
the youngest but what I also didn't
understand was how Gundry was going to
know his way back this is the first time
again jury has ever been north of the
wall so unless you can actually see the
wall from where they were he might have
had some trouble getting back unless
their footprints were still in the snow
we can't actually be sure how far away
they were but it had to be close to the
three-eyed Ravens cave because the
arrowhead shape Mountain was right there
and that's where the children of the
forest created the night king they end
up spending at least one night stuck on
the rock in the middle of the lake and
thoris Amir dies during the night and I
was actually kind of surprised the night
King didn't raised Thoreau's while they
all had their eyes closed he could have
raised Thoreau's in the middle of the
night and killed at least one or two of
them but I'm also glad he didn't because
I like Thoris of Maher and I wouldn't
want to see him come back like that but
it was a smart move for them to burn his
body if I were them I would have taken
ginjuries hammer and broken all the ice
around the rock and every time it
started to freeze again I would have
taken the hammer and broken it all again
at least until Damaris showed up back in
Winterfell Songza receives word from
King's Landing the parlay scene is
starting to be set in motion in the next
episode we will see nearly all of the
main characters gather at the dragon pit
to discuss terms about the upcoming war
for the dawn I was pretty surprised
Sansa was so quick to send Breen away I
know she doesn't want to be treated as a
child but with all the tension in
Winterfell you think she'd want the
protection not only is Arya breathing
down her neck
but Sanjay knows firsthand exactly what
Littlefinger is capable of and willing
to do back on Dragonstone Daenerys has
received a raven - and it's telling her
that John and Jorah and everybody else
is in some serious trouble and I have no
idea how the Raven got there so fast but
we also have no sense of time in the
show anymore we don't know if days or
weeks are passing by with each scene the
timelines and the way people travel in
this world is a mystery to me I was
pretty disappointed in Tyrion though he
did not want Daenerys going to help them
and I understand he was trying to keep
her safe but I was expecting Tyrion to
show a little more compassion for John
and Jorah does Tyrion really think they
can survive the winter without John
because I don't you need him just as
much as you need Daenerys back beyond
the wall someone should have told the
Hound you shouldn't throw stones when
you live in a glass house he threw a
rock that was today and begging and went
bouncing across the ice
letting the white know that the ice is
now frozen solid and this is when the
battle begins I am a sucker for battle
scenes what can I say I thoroughly
enjoyed watching some of my favorite
characters fight this massive army of
whites it was very entertaining in my
opinion seeing Barrack with the flaming
sword and John with long haul and Jorah
with his dual dragon glass daggers and
torment in the Hound side-by-side I
thought it was outstanding
then Daenerys shows up and starts
raining dragon fire on them all I have
been waiting so long to see the dragons
and the whites and White Walkers and
Knight King and the same scene together
I had a lot of fun watching this
sequence but then the inevitable
happened one of the dragons was killed
in epic fashion the night came channeled
his inner Tom Brady and he launched an
ice spear about a quarter mile into the
sky now I knew he had superhuman
strength but damn he has a cannon for an
arm I know some people were wondering
why he didn't kill drove on instead
since Dragoon was literally like a
hundred feet away from him just sitting
on the ground my only guess is he saw
this area as the bigger threat at that
moment since Dragoon was turned around
shooting fire in the opposite direction
he saw this area on heading his way
shooting fire and he figured he better
take him down first
since Dragoon was already landed on the
ground and they were waiting for John I
think he thought if he took the seryan
out first drug on would still be there
because
John wasn't on him yet and then he could
take his second shot at drug on too but
that's just a guess but anyways John
gets tackled into the damn lake so
Damaris has to take off before the night
team takes out drug on too and I know
some of you was asking me on Twitter
about John sword while John was under
the water the eyes were closed on the
sword but when John came up and took his
breath the eyes appeared to open I think
there are some type of stones for its
eyes because when John came up and the
water splashed and made the stones look
black and you can actually see them
glisten as John grabs the sword and
climbs out you might have to watch it on
slow motion to see it though and it
could be symbolic too but I don't think
so it just appeared that way when John
does get back out of the water he's
nearly overrun by all the whites as he
suffers from hypothermia but then Benjen
ex machina shows up just in time to give
John his horse to escape personally I
think Benton could have gotten on the
horse too when he saved bran and Mira he
put both of them on his horse so there
was three people on his horse at one
time so he could have easily picked John
up and rode off with him too it
definitely would have slowed the horse
down significantly if two people were on
it but Benjamin today go out in style
I respect him for that but I will also
miss him too I just hope he doesn't come
back as a full-blown white and John is
forced to kill him but it did feel good
to hear John actually get to say Uncle
Benjen and actually see him again John
get to see him one last time although
was extremely brief John actually died
thinking someone knew where his uncle
Benjen was but this time his uncle
Benjen actually saved his life
we all knew John was going to be saved
somehow so this wasn't a surprise but I
was still pleased to get to see his
uncle one more time everyone else makes
it back to the wall when the Hound gets
the white in the boat to take the King's
Landing for the next episodes big parler
scene John shows up just in time before
they leave and they get him on the boat
and strip him out of his frozen clothes
and Daenerys is actually watching and
she sees all of John's scores from when
he was killed
when I was looking at John's scars I
couldn't help but think of the night
King the night King took a dagger to his
chest so John and the night King have
both been stabbed in the heart and I
wonder if there's some deeper meaning to
this that has yet to be revealed we get
some more foreshadowing here to when we
get our third reference in this episode
about someone having
children John wakes up and apologizes
for versary on being killed InDinero
says the dragons are the only children
she will ever have but like I said
before John and Danny will hook up and
John will get her pregnant
I think vissarion's death will pay for
life allowing for Daenerys to get
pregnant by John I am actually 100%
confident this will happen before season
8 ends Daenerys gives John her word they
will destroy the night king together
John now has some of the support he has
been looking for now he just needs
Cersei to play ball John calls Daenerys
his queen and he said he would bend the
knee if he physically could but he
actually really didn't have to now that
she agreed to help him but I think John
mostly offered this because he felt bad
about this area and dying he could see
how shaken up she was about this but
Daenerys also proved her worth to John
she didn't have to show up and save him
but she put her life and her dragons
lives in danger to save John and the
others and John recognizes that Annie
appreciates that Plus earlier in the
episode
tormund reminded John that Mans didn't
bend his knee and thousands of people
had to die because of that and John
doesn't want his people to meet the same
fate this episode ends with the whites
pulling the dragon out of the water and
I know everyone has been asking about
these chains and I'm just going to
assume they got these chains from Hart
home because many ships have docked
there before the night king did take
full control of Hart home so I am sure
they sacked the place for everything
that it had but where he got those
chains really isn't that important at
this point because the night king now
has a dragon and he's going to use this
dragon to get past the wall with his
entire army we should see his entire
army of the Dead south of the wall when
season 8 begins now they just have to
hope this white will convince Cersei to
provide them with the support to stop
the army of the dead but Cersei is not
going to care about that right now she
is only worried about the immediate
threat to her throne if Cersei never
ends up helping them then Viserion
basically died for nothing
other than helping the night king seem
even more unstoppable than he already is
there was obviously a lot of
inconsistencies with this episode so
many things didn't make sense logically
but this happens almost every episode
now so I'm not all bent out of shape
about it I still thoroughly enjoyed this
episode any time I can see my favorite
characters fight
the dead I'm pretty happy with that
because it's always fun to watch and I
also enjoyed all the callbacks and
references as everyone reminisced about
people they knew from the past like I
said earlier in this video I really
enjoy scenes where characters are just
traveling together and talking that's
usually when we get some of the best
dialogue in the episodes but comment
down below and let me know what you
thought about this episode what did you
like what did you hate I'm going to
start working on my episode 7 preview
trailer breakdown video that way I can
release that tomorrow so I hope you all
come back for that thank you so much for
taking the time to watch this one and as
always thank you to my patreon
supporters I hope you all have a great
day and I'll see you down in the comment
section bye
[Music]
you
[Music]